Shariff alaikum music so kind of like
blind a mood and you guys don't have to
hear yeah I don't have maybe like turn
off all the lights and like leave no we
do that kiss with horizon but you just
kind of you just close your eyes when
you get in like that's all I think it's
haven't been done
I've been between us I would say yes
yeah I think I've watched tuned but I
don't think he's ever watched me watch
him doing not not probably for a long
period of time but just as like a joke
yeah I feel as a joke I think I probably
peaked but like never like full-blown
like honestly yeah honestly yeah like I
like to see when I'm like what I'm
kissing you know and what's a dog - of
course
[Music]
Oh a we're good to go all right so all
right we might need to warm up like a
like one of those like a normal kiss
like that like I was like a quick I
gotta take my glasses off um I have a
mint
oh the contacts are drying out it I'm
not horrible pain I feel like we're
doing the trauma I feel like I've
forgotten how to kiss
you look like a cyclops it's like your
eyes are oh god that's the longest ever
that's not like a worse kid I don't know
he's hot I don't know but you go for you
try to drive down myself I didn't care
for it we normally just way better than
that I'm sweating right now
it was good that's hot uh that was that
was good that's the stuff nightmares
definitely different they're gonna try
this at home
I might it's about responsibility like
me me me also just don't do those I
wonder if there's something in like
kinetic says like do not open that one
kissing it's like when you sneeze ten
into ten when I do that again
[Music]